vous l'avez dit c'est donc demain la
veille de face et donc demain la
réouverture de wall street voyons à
présent les conséquences de communiquer
après les attentats elles sont déjà
palpables avec les très grandes
difficultés pour certaines compagnies
aériennes qui ont mis à pied certains de
leurs salariés la maison blanche et le
congrès s'inquiètent les nouvelles
estimation chiffrée des dégâts avec
elisabeth et ses
six jours sans cotation à wall street on
n'avait jamais vu ça depuis la première
guerre mondiale derniers préparatifs
avant la réouverture demain à l'heure
habituelle mais dans un climat qui ne
sera pas beaucoup d'incertitudes et
d'appréhension chez les investisseurs
qui s'attendent à une baisse importante
de l'ordre de 5 à 10% déjà vendredi
l'éventualité d'une réplique américaine
aux attentats avaient entraîné une
nouvelle déroute des indices européens
c'est le transport aérien qui souffre le
plus dans le monde entier les compagnies
américaines étant bien sûr les plus
touchées elles perdent actuellement plus
de 7 milliards de francs par jour
continental airlines vient d'annoncer la
mise en chômage technique de 12000 de
ses salariés près d'un sur cinq lourd
tribut également pour les sociétés
d'assurance qui attendent une aide de
l'état américain
face à un drame d'une telle ampleur dont
la responsabilité est un acte de guerre
sans doute on voit difficilement comment
les pouvoirs publics américains ne
seront pas appelés à assumer leurs
responsabilités
on voit bien qu'il y a un problème
d'ordre d'ordre public on voit bien
qu'il ya un problème de sécurité
nationale et c'est un acte de guerre
commis contre les états unis dont la
cima et et des biens privés et des et de
ville même pour l'instant rien n'est
encore acquis pour régler la facture du
sinistre le plus cher de l'histoire en
incluant l'indemnisation des entreprises
qui étaient installés dans les tours et
celle des familles la note pourrait
s'élever à 100 200 voire 300 milliards
de francs